so next thing you know the director text
me is like well look man uh David Spade
recommended you and I'm like oh wow
that's crazy because first of all David
Spade is one of my favorite entertainers
of all time
I mean you know the fact I mean we have
Chris Farley his uh painting of Chris
Farley up here in our studio and the
fact that he got to work with him black
sheep Tommy Boy
you know what's the the movie uh I think
he was in sin of a woman I think or
something I don't know but or he just
gets a lot of huh say you know I'm but
um but I love David Spade Oh Joe Dirt
and people you know and I thought Joe
Dirt a lot of people know this I thought
it was a documentary when I first saw it
and I remember when I finally got to
interview David Spade he came on
allegedly which uh was a podcast that
I've done with Matthew Cole Weiss for a
while and he came on and allegedly and
he's like and and I was like hey did a
lot of orphans like reach out to you
when Joe Dirt came out and he's like
what are you talking about and I was
like whoa and I explained to him you
know and he's like dude that's not a
[ __ ] documentary he's like you're an
idiot and I was like oh that's awesome
and you know David Spade is call me an
idiot and made me feel good but anyhow
so next thing you know the director is
like why don't you get in touch with
David Spade and I'm like I don't know
David Spade's number you know I'm saying
dude I'm not just walking around with
people like David Spade's number or
people like you know who else Kris
Kringle freaking Rain Man anybody else
dude Wolverine who the [ __ ] does this
guy think I am you know Katy Perry I
don't have just ultimate numbers in my
phone
so he sends me David Spade's number and
like oh wow what do I do with David
Spade's number so I'm like just like I'm
like I don't really call Dave and I know
David Spade through we have a mutual
friend Adam egit who booked who's the
Booker at the Comedy Store and I know
him through just seeing him in Circle
and we chat sometimes a little bit in
these yeah I would consider his buddies
but I wouldn't say that we're really
friends yet you know because we just
haven't know him well enough and I you
know it's that weird thing we're like I
don't want to it like I don't feel like
a fanboy at around him or anything but I
am a fan of his work so it's you know
it's it's not a it's not uncomfortable
but it's it's um you know there's an
admiration there that sometimes I get
excited about maybe I can't hide and he
might be like and uh this is a fun
conversation but your cheeks are all
flushed or your eyes are flickering
while we're talking you know or your
erect like what's going on buddy so you
know sometime I can't hide my you know
just genuine excitement that God just
sends out just vibing out through my
through my you know my eyelids or
through my even my crotch sometimes if
I'm you know keyed up or excited so next
thing you know I have David Spade's
number and I call it goes to voicemail
and then I get a call back and this is
um and so I'm like well what the hell
how do I do I stand up do I sit down and
I'm saying do I lay down how do I answer
the phone David Spade calls so you know
I'm just trying to like I go outside I
was inside of a loud place and I'm like
I don't want him to think that I you
know hang out in loud places you know I
don't know what the [ __ ] I was thinking
dude and then I was like oh dude I don't
feel like I'm very tall because I always
have this thing in my head like I don't
feel like um cuz I am 6 feet tall even
though some people will say I'm not and
if you look at like old you know older
if you use like an old [ __ ] ruler
from a long time ago where they didn't
really put that full inch in there then
yeah then I definitely make it but if
you use kind of these newer rulers where
things are a lot more can you know
certain I don't get there and I think I
get there and some people say I don't
but I think I come in right at six feet
you know and strong that looking you
know I'm so if you know I'm right there
5:11 and 7/8 dude and if the wind blows
up or they don't [ __ ] kind of pick me
up just enough to get me at that six
foot but I always have these
insecurities you know how the
insecurities of having that you know I
have a limited neck my neck doesn't go
very far even we've talked about that on
here and I talk about it a lot
you know I'm saying I can't really look
around that much so after you to look
forward or I have to turn around and
then also look forward which is behind
me at that point cuz I turned around and
so next thing you know man I so I stand
on a bench there's a bench right there
so I'm like well [ __ ] I want to sound
tall when I talk to David Spade on the
phone even though re know he already
knows how tall I am
right so next he know I'm on the phone
and he's like he starts telling me about
the video and I said we'll look I just
you know I'm a little nervous I want to
be seen as like a pervert you know I
don't want to be seen as a a PDF file
and so he's like nah man he's like this
is a chance for you to like act you know
like you you get to be funny a lot but
you get to be you know creepy and dark
and I'm like well you know I have a I
said I've struggled over my life with
you know masturbation and stuff like
that and he's like what the [ __ ] you
talking about I was like I don't know
and so then we kind of thankfully got
out of that topic for a second but I was
trying to tell him how I've been into
some dark arts or any you know you know
I've had some issues and addiction
issues and stuff but um he's just like
look this is a chance for you to play a
creeper you can be a creeper and that's
it so next thing you know I text the
director and I said I'm in and two days
later I'm on I'm on set with bad bad
baby I mean look this [ __ ] up I thought
it was be hot baby and then I thought I
was like well her fan base has to be
called be Haj jihad right but it is it
is bad behead bad
when I first thought is like is she have
sheep on her yeah Danielle bra goalie
that be had baby you know catch me
outside
so anyway next you on one set and boom
there I am and I'm on it's like and dude
it to a real music video there's like
smoke and there are there's like a table
in the distance with everybody eating
orange slices and like fancy oranges
like oranges from [ __ ] Sweden or
Portland and everybody's you know they
have all kind of cashews and uh and they
have uh you know people they have some
dudes walking on with radios and [ __ ]
weren't doing
[ __ ] but just you know carrying around
electronics basically and it was in in
so next II know I'm in this dude I'm
playing I'm playing a pervert and I'm
playing a pervert and and we did we did
the whole video and and we did a night
shoot and it was in it was wild and then
I came back two days later we did some
pick-me-ups so it's just gonna be
something you're gonna be able to it was
the craziest thing like you would never
think I would be in that and and then
there I was man but the crazy party is
here's one of the weirdest things so you
know a couple of my friends knew about
it and I don't even know if I'm supposed
to tell anybody about it but you know
what I'm saying this is this is what we
do on here we just say what what's going
on and so and my buddies are texting me
and they're like hey man that chick is
so hot bro
set me up and what dude what are you
talking I'm playing a pervert bruh
because of God like you because of guys
like you I'm here and this is the role
of men so it was just intense man our
buddies like set me up with her
my total must set you up with a child
but there's a lot that's called sex
trafficking that's called sex
trafficking man so it's just you know
it's just wild but then also you know
she gets its while how we sexualized I
don't want to say that we sexualized
children but there's the industry like
you know you'll put a young girl and
have her look sexual you know if they're
developed you'll have them look sexual
and I just start to wonder like I guess
there's if somebody's a you know is
really a pervert then they're just they
can't they don't know when to say okay
that's a that is a child or that's a kid
or that's legally not okay and then you
know and then it is okay you know
because that starting line is 18 so
that's the starting line but uh but yeah
I guess that's the difference if some
people can't shut down that part of
their brain where they want to you know
Joe
you know they want to you know coach
children's softball or whatever or that
kind of stuff anyway I don't know why I
got in all that but you can see me in a
bad baby music video coming out and look
I was so nervous like there's one part
where I'm like because she catches me
and I'm like pin down on this like
Dexter style deal on my [ __ ] you know
and uh and I'm like and I even said to
the director I was like dude I just want
to like I'm okay with I said just tell
me this tell me if I look like somebody
who can't act trying to act that's what
I do not want to look like that he's
like nah man you did a good job and it
was but it was pretty crazy man it was
just crazy it was crazy to be in there
and uh and people are like well what's
Danielle bergoglio like what's behind
baby like and I said well she's the cash
me outside girl you know she ought you
know and that's who she is and she's
also a kid she's nice she's uh she's a
ninth grader so when you talk to it's
like talking to somebody in the ninth
grade
you know but she definitely had a lot of
swagger she was definitely fun she was
fun to be around she had a good sense of
humor I thought like the second time we
did pickup shots which was last night or
two nights ago she made it like it was
it was easy to joke around and stuff
right there I mean if anything what I
realized about myself was that
definitely because I look I haven't been
around a fifteen-year I don't hang out
around any people this age and so good
hey first of all you know and it was
just you know I realized like oh yeah
these these kids this is another
generation they live in a world that I
do not know about and I am thankful that
I don't know about it and I'm thankful
that I'm just here playing a pervert or
PDF file today just as an actor and not
suffering with that in my real life and
I'm grateful for that man because I
remember being in college and I was in
college and I was at Louisiana State
University and I'm a we had a professor
and he came into class one day it was
like statistics or something like that
her
something like that and he comes in and
he goes um statistically speaking this
he's like there's 800 people in here so
it was first year because there's 800
800 800 students in here statistically
speaking you know 170 of you guys will
get divorced statistically speaking you
know for you guys will be in a lawsuit
because you you know burns your arm at a
pizza hut or something and then
statistically speaking to you guys will
be convicted of pedophile pedophilia or
something and a second I heard that I
remember to stand and up dude in the
middle of that class and just saying not
it that's what I said I said not it and
I made that line and the stand right in
the sand I made the line in the sand
right then for myself that I wasn't
gonna sit around and let that rule that
wall that that roulette ball a life just
bouncing laying wherever it wanted to on
me that I was gonna stand up and say not
it today professor I'm not being a damn
pervert from my life you know it's crazy
as my sister can't even read but what
does it have to do with us right now
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one